-♪ Virtual Reality Pictionary ♪
-But first,
we're going to need partners,
and we found some good ones.
Joining Tariq's team,
he stars in
"Pirates of the Caribbean:
Dead Men Tell No Tales."
Give it up for Orlando Bloom!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now, brother.
-I'm winning tonight!
-I know.
All right, all right.
Get ready, man.
It's going down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Give it up for Orlando Bloom.
Okay.
I got a good partner, too.
My partner tonight,
she wrote, directed, and stars
in the new movie "Band Aid."
Please welcome Zoe Lister-Jones!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Zoe.
Orlando -- Zoe.
Thank you for being here, pal.
Were gonna do this.
Now, the game works
exactly like Pictionary,
except the person who is drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual-reality headsets, okay?
And drawing in 3-D space
using this program
called Tilt Brush.
We're able to see
their point of view
up on the big screen,
upstage.
45 seconds per turn.
I'll go first.
You guys
can all take your seats.
Here we go.
All right, what do I --
I have to choose
one number first, right?
-Five.
-Thank you, sir.
Five.
Weird.
Why did one guy just yell five?
[ Laughter ]
"Five."
It sounded like it was rigged.
I'm not gonna choose five.
I don't want anyone thinking
the show's rigged.
What else?
-Three!
-Nah, that sounded
even more rigged.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Three!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
All right.
All right, ready?
Are we going?
How far can I walk?
-You're -- You're good.
You got room, you got room.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
Here we go.
-Uh...
Oh, what?
A -- A man?
A cowboy.
Pirate.
-Yeah, mm-hmm.
-Okay.
"Pirates of the Caribbean 8."
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
Tha-- That --
[ Laughter ]
A pi-- A pi--
[ Laughs ]
A what?
A pirate crotch.
A pi-- A pi--
-Crotch?
-Where are you pointing?
Oh, a p-- A p--
Pirate booty?
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We did it!
We did it, we did it.
-Whew!
Man, oh, man.
Whew! We did it.
All right, here we go.
Orlando, you're up next, pal.
-Oh!
-Yeah, beat that, man.
-Beat that.
-All right, here you go.
I'll hand you the trigger.
Oh, before you put it on,
Orlando, let's pick a number.
-All right.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Four.
I don't see it.
-Six!
-Seven!
-We already picked four.
We're good.
-Can I change it?
-No!
-You said --
Somebody said five.
-No, it's four!
-Cheater!
-You don't want to do four?
All right.
-Wow, wow.
-Yeah, it was bad.
-Yeah.
-Don't -- Don't go for four.
-Wait.
Where's the thing?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
-Are you freaking out right now?
-Yeah,
I'm freaking out right now.
-Careful.
-Oh, this is so beautiful.
I'm just gonna
stay here forever.
-Right?
It's just fantastic, right?
-How long have we got?
All right.
-Here we go.
We're going.
-Um...palm -- palm tree.
-You can walk around it, too.
It's 3-D.
-Duck?
A duck.
-Wow. That's pretty good.
-Chicken. A chicken coop.
Chicken...
[ Laughter ]
Um...
"Duck Tales."
Uh...
-Oh!
-What is this?
Duck -- Duck chair?
A du--
A sitting duck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Holy mackerel!
That was impressive!
Wow!
Well done!
That was great.
-Wow.
-Wow. All right, pal.
We can do this.
-Oh, I have to choose it first.
One? Okay.
-Here you go.
-Okay.
-Boy, that was nice --
sitting duck.
Man, oh, man.
-Okay.
-Zoe, we got this, man.
-Yeah. Uh, we'll see.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-That's the confidence I love
in my teammate.
-Okay. Ready?
-Yes, I'm ready.
-Okay.
-Oh. Ooh.
Is that a pig?
-Yep.
-It is?
-Yeah.
-When pigs fly.
-No.
-What is the --
Pig back.
Piggy back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Record time! Record time!
-Wow!
-The dream team.
Dream team.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-Tariq, you're up.
-Choose four.
-You have to use --
You have to --
-Choose four.
-No, don't --
don't choose four.
He already read four.
-Choose four.
-Don't look at four.
-Four.
I could play that one now.
-Oh, okay. Cool.
-Got to start something.
-Fish. Shark.
-Sitting fish.
-Fish. Ocean.
Sea.
Starfish? No?
Is it a fish?
Uh...
That's a table
with something on it.
-You don't have to build
the whole room Tariq, God.
[ Laughter ]
Holy mackerel.
-Uh...
Okay. Uh...
Where are we?
Uh...
Knife.
Fish and chips!
Fish and chips.
Uh...
No.
-Of course you would say
fish and chips.
-Knife.
Swordfish! Swordfish!
No, table, fish, fish...
Restaurant.
-2 seconds!
-Fish restaurant?
-Oh.
What was it?
-Goldfish?
-It was "sushi bar."
-Sushi bar?!
[ Laughter ]
Bro! Bro!
Help me out, man!
-[ Laughing ]
-Sushi.
You could've drawn a little
sushi and I'd have guessed it!
-No, no, that was great.
That's what it's like before
the customers get in there.
All right, now it's time
for the final round.
There's gonna be a showdown
worth triple the points.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Orlando, you are going to draw.
-Ooh.
-If Tariq guesses
the clue first,
then you guys win, okay?
If Zoe --
If Zoe or I gets it,
then we win.
-Yeah.
-All right, here we go.
Orlando, you can grab a clue.
-You can even grab four
if you want to.
-I can grab four now.
Staying away from four.
What?!
[ Audience shouting ]
Eight?
-No, no, no.
-Eight?
-Nine.
-Nine?
-There you go -- nine.
Anyone's round.
-Oh-ho!
[ Laughter ]
-Wait a minute!
Hold on! Hold on!
Grab the stick, yeah.
-Grab the stick.
Okay, here I go.
I'm ready.
-All right, come on,
we got this.
Zoe, we can do this.
-We got this.
-Okay.
This is gonna be interesting.
-Man.
-Uh...
Ice cream man.
Man on a...
-Man hat.
-Thought?
Toupee!
Hairpiece!
Trump!
-Tomato man.
[ Laughter ]
-What is an egg?
-Sushi bar!
[ Laughter ]
Uh, idea.
-Man, football,
football player.
Man of a --
-Bread.
-Bread -- what?
-Baguette.
-Roll man.
-Baguette. Baker.
A baker!
-Man toast.
-Chef! A chef!
A ball on the top of his head.
-Roll man.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh! That was hard!
-What?
-Man bun!
-Oh, man.
It's a man!
-Man bun.
-I mean,
I think that was pretty genius.
-No, it was actually good.
That was a good man bun.
-That was actually
kind of genius.
-Zoe?
Are we -- Can we still go?
Yeah, we can still go, right?
-We're going again?
-I think, right?
What do we do?
Zoe --
No, Zoe, you do it.
-Okay. What's the number?
-All right, what is the number?
[ Audience shouting ]
All right, pressure's on.
-Oh, God. Okay.
-Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing, man.
Good luck.
-I'm feeling good.
-Yeah.
Okay. All right.
-Come on, pardsy, you can do it.
-This could get dirty.
-Oh!
-Zoe, no, no, no, no, no.
All right, here we go.
-Uh-huh.
-Come on, pal.
We can do this.
Gotcha.
-Okay.
-Gotcha.
Always starts like that.
-I know, I know but just --
-Pig. A pig.
-Dog, dog.
-No, hold on.
-Camel.
-Camelback, camel toe.
Camel, hump.
Water -- water.
Camel hump. Water.
-Hump. Humpty dance!
-No.
-Uh, hump -- hump --
-Humpback whale.
-Hump day.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna be happy for them,
but still...
How do you get "hump day"?
-I mean, I don't know.
-That's fantastic.
That's the champs right there.
Orlando Bloom, Tariq Trotter!
Zoe Lister-Jones.